hey Conan here and this is my video
response I just watched the trailer
Pacific Rim a Warner Brothers picture
I'm irritated I was very excited about
this movie
I heard Pacific Rim and I thought
finally someone has made a big-budget
100 million dollar movie about the
incredible cuisine of Indonesia China
Japan Los Angeles San Francisco Seattle
great blend of tastes cultural
smorgasbord I was excited I'm a bit of a
foodie and then bang I find out that's
not what it's about at all you know they
should have just called this movie
robots punch monsters robots punch
monsters or just robot robot monster
robot hit monster
something like that you get it right
away you're not confused by another
question looks to me like the giant
robots have conspicuous crotch bulges
why that's there why would a scientist
put that in there they're clearly pervs
we need giant robots yes putting a bulge
in the crook why she's well it contained
weapon no putting a bulge will we
storage creep so anyway I don't know
that I'll see I may go just because I
have a seven-year-old son and apparently
he wrote the screenplay burned check
yourself into the hospital you've been
burned Pacific Rim anyway subscribe to
my channel
you